Karla is with us hey in Louisiana hey
Karla how are you hey I'm doing great
thanks for answering my call sure we're
gonna help my husband is getting ready
to start his senior year of mechanical
engineering he has an internship
getting great and he works hard time my
question is you have about a year left I
saw your post about Sallie Mae having
record profits it made me really angry
so Maya yes so my question is do we
couldn't holiday while he is in school
because I from what I heard you can only
consolidate alone one yes and that is
that repayment and interest rate is it
better to do it while he's on part-time
I'm a stay-at-home mom with the baby and
he's working two jobs interning
full-time student do i consolidate now
with the $20,000 income that we have or
do I wait until I graduate but he is he
is he through taking out loans he on we
will find out on the first he is
applying for merit-based scholarship
because this is his second bachelor's he
couldn't get any but we're getting hit
$200 a month in interest from Sallie Mae
so do we consolidate now based off this
income or do we wait until after he
graduates and starts making engineer
money so what do you got like 30 $40,000
in debt it's already accruing interest
33,000 yeah okay all right I would not
consolidate if you're gonna add more
debt because you say no but as you said
you get will you get one shot at this
and so it's not gonna matter much when
you get a lower interest rate it's not
it's not gonna change anything that much
$200 a month is $2,400 a year $2,400 a
year's not your problem 33,000 is er
even if you cut your interest rate in
half it's only a thousand twelve a 1200
difference and you're not gonna cut it
yeah because we our interest rate right
now is ten and a half percent and his
credit score is 790 I don't understand
why's that
and then the consolidation way and they
said they could offer us four to six no
more than 600 if you if you did drop it
in half it saves you a thousand dollars
okay and my second question is someone
told me that you want to make sure that
it says you don't loan because there's
certain protections if the title is
student loan instead of like the
signature loan right it's just so this
is it needs to be a Sallie Mae or a
navient blown it doesn't need to be any
else because the protections are if you
die the loan is forgiven or if you
become permanently disabled the longest
forgiving are their student loan
consolidate are their consolidation
loans with the protection yes yes tons
of them yeah it shouldn't be any trouble
at all to do that but again it's not
your biggest issue it's a thousand
dollars out of a thirty three thousand
dollar problem
so it's okay to do it it doesn't hurt
anything but the bigger issue stop
borrowing more that's a much bigger
thing to concentrate on than whether or
not to refinance